when it comes to cinematic Terror in the
water we've got sharks in the Pacific
we've got sharks in the Atlantic and
we've even got sharks in the streets of
Los Angeles here are the shark movies
you have to see before you die
bait 3D is the 2012 Australian
Singaporean movie about people who
survive a freak tidal wave only to be
trapped in a partially submerged grocery
store and hunted by a pack of
bloodthirsty great whites and it sounds
like a special breed of made for TV
stupidity but it's actually a
surprisingly tense ride the stranded
crew must deal with robberies Sparks
from split wires being trapped on store
shelves without an obvious way out and
of course plenty of close calls with
carnivorous monster fish Bates initial
critical reception was lukewarm it
currently holds a 47 rating on Rotten
Tomatoes but if you're the type of
moviegoer who Thrills at Creature
Feature genre fair you should find
plenty to love here a sequel called Deep
Water about a plane crashing in the
Pacific Ocean was planned for a 2014
release but it was yanked from the
schedule after it was decided that the
plot was too similar to the Malaysian
Airlines flight 370 disaster still the
first one holds up well enough for a
night in with a full bowl of popcorn
technically the Meg isn't really about a
shark at all but it's close enough that
we absolutely had to include it based on
Steve Alton's 1997 book Meg a novel of
deep Terror this goofy 2018 sci-fi
thriller Stars Jason Statham is the
leader of a rescue mission that heads to
the floor of the Pacific Ocean that's
where the characters run smack into a
monstrous 75-foot Megalodon a
prehistoric Titan that makes great
whites look like goldfish it was thought
to be extinct but it turns out it is
very much alive and very hungry to give
you an idea of how seriously to take
this movie there's a scene in which the
characters watch the Beast devour a
humpback whale and a single Chomp right
outside their underwater research
station and there's another moment when
they immobilize it by ramming into its
midsection with a submarine a swarm of
smaller more modern sharks that are
attracted to its blood then set upon it
like piranhas and eat it alive the Meg
is certainly no Masterpiece but it's
more than enough fun to justify a watch
as Forbes critic Scott Mendelson put it
the Meg is fun plain and simple it's a
polished B movie that delivers the goods
if not the greats and it's worth
whatever your local theater charges for
a weekend matinee is there anything more
we can ask of a big budget Creature
Feature Chomp away be safe yeah thanks
Bill
the 2017 release 47 meters down explores
the ultimate fear of anyone who's ever
watched a video of a cage dive in shark
infested waters what if the cable snaps
well there's that and then there's also
the fear of the Sharks nudging their
weight Between the Bars in this movie
the cable doesn't eat snap and sisters
Lisa and Kate quickly find themselves
trapped with a dwindling oxygen supply
on an ocean floor patrolled by hungry
great whites 47 meters down offers a
great little twist on the typical shark
movie formula that doesn't push things
too far it didn't blow every critic away
but the fact that this little sharp
flick had as much bite as it did was the
surprise in and of itself varieties Joe
Laden enthused director Johannes Roberts
mostly underwater Thriller is a compact
and sturdily crafted Bee Movie that
generates enough scares and suspense to
qualify as well maybe not a pleasant
surprise but a reasonably entertaining
one there's no reason that Sharknado
should actually work its title isn't a
particularly clever play on words this
is literally a movie about a tornado
filled with sharks that throws the Beast
all over Greater Los Angeles and a group
of survivors who leap into their mouths
with chainsaws but surely you knew that
already and you probably didn't know how
to feel about this movie when you first
saw it on the surface it looks like any
other schlocky made for TV sci-fi movie
but this one refuses to make the same
mistakes others in its goofy genre do by
taking itself even slightly seriously it
knows it's absurd you can laugh at it
but it's right there laughing at itself
right alongside you Sharknado went on to
win over the masses and even some
critics as well bizarrely it somehow
currently holds a 78 score on Rotten
Tomatoes without a doubt it was one of
the most talked about films of 2013.
once again and we cannot stress this
enough this is a movie about a tornado
filled with sharks the New York daily
news's David Hinckley said it best when
he declared Sharknado is an hour and a
half of your life that you'll never get
back and you won't want to but even a
movie that subverts expectations this
hard ultimately couldn't save itself
from five lame sequels each subject to
increasingly diminishing returns still
the 2013 original is an utterly bizarre
gloriously brainless wonderful little
gem
we'll just come right out and say it
Alzheimer's experiments involving
genetically modified animals rarely end
well for movie characters but we didn't
have to wait for 2011's rise at the
Planet of the Apes to figure that out we
only needed to have seen deep blue sea a
silly but thoroughly fun 1999 sci-fi
horror flick in which genetically
engineered super smart sharks rampaged
through an underwater lab the enhanced
shark brains that make these monsters so
lethal and by just as many comparisons
to Jurassic Park's Velociraptors as they
do to the big bad from Jaws good luck
getting trapped in a Sea Lab with these
things lurking around
deep blue sea was reasonably well
received when it came out but its Legacy
has grown even more with time writing
for Wired in 2016 Brian Rafferty offered
High Praise calling it quotes the
greatest non-jaws shark movie of all
time this was thanks to its inventive
action set pieces and fairly
well-rounded human characters other
moments like Samuel L Jackson's
Unforgettable death scene and the Very
idea of intelligent sharks have led
plenty of other viewers to declare deep
blue sea one of the best shark flicks
ever made after all it's hard to argue
with the combination of Sam Jackson and
hungry animals
the jaw series may be the earliest
available proof that capturing lightning
in a bottle once doesn't mean that
sequels will be able to do the same the
franchise ultimately got crushed under
the weight of diminishing returns with
the release of joyless flops like jaws
3D and Jaws the Revenge but 1978's Jaws
2 in which the first film's Chief Brody
faces off against another great white
and a battle to save the lives of his
stranded children and their friends
isn't half bad it doesn't quite
recapture the magic of the original but
it wasn't reasonable to expect it to in
the first place Jaws 2 is 10 swell acted
well-paced occasionally funny and
jam-packed with all the killer shark
action fans of the original had come to
expect there's a scene in which the
shark leaps out of the water and
literally brings down the helicopter
sending propeller shards through the
sails of the stranded boats and there's
another in which we get to revisit Chief
Brody's habit of killing sharks by
jamming explosives into their mouths
what more could you want
foreign
Australia gets another entry on this
list in the form of 2010's the reef
after all what other country could you
trust to be an authority on the
existential danger of nature this movie
follows a group of friends whose
sailboat capsizes on their way to
Indonesia naturally a great white shark
catches wind of this and decides to swim
in to try to grab some lunch one of the
most notable aspects of this movie is
that it features actual footage of
sharks as opposed to lifeless
animatronics or cringe-worthy CGI
overall The Reef works because it knows
exactly what it is it also knows what
the limitations of its genre are and it
doesn't try to entertain Beyond its
means it has a tight script with no fat
to trim and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that a French review site put
it perfectly when it declared the reef
turns out to be a good little friendly
film that was able to demonstrate a good
dose of realism and efficiency
unlike a lot of other movies on this
list Open Water doesn't Revel in glepel
over the top absurdity instead it's a
gritty tense terrifying Thriller that's
Loosely based on the true story of Tom
and Eileen Lonergan married scuba divers
who were accidentally left behind by
their dive group near the Great Barrier
Reef and never seen again since little
is known about what actually happened to
the actual loner against the makers of
Open Water had to use their imaginations
to tell its story of course sharks are
involved and that may very well be the
most obvious Peril in a story about
people stranded at sea but it's not the
only life-threatening problem scenes of
the couple starving struggling with
extreme thirst and exposure and being
tortured by mental anguish as they wait
for the inevitable all add to a sense of
inescapable dread by the time the Sharks
swing by it's practically merciful
critics Heap to claim on the film few of
them praising it as highly as Roger
Ebert who raved rarely but sometimes a
movie can have an actual physical effect
on you it gets under your defenses and
sidesteps the it's only a movie reflex
and creates a visceral feeling that
might as well be real so check out Open
Water if you dare
it's the stuff of nightmares imagine
being completely alone stranded on the
bloating carcass of a half-eaten whale
while a great white shark prowls around
with a whip of your blood and an empty
stomach that's the situation that Blake
Lively finds herself in in the shallows
an airtight lethally crafted Thriller
that had critics cheering mad solar
sites wrote on Roger ebert.com Lively is
superb here giving one of those
hyper-focused action-led performances
that's as much an athletic feat as an
aesthetic one and IGN's Simon Thompson
raved the shallows does for surfing with
the Blair Witch Project did for camping
and makes Jaws look like a children's
tea party played out with precision and
skill it delivers everything it suggests
it will and then some terrifyingly good
it should come as no surprise that
1975's Jaws is the Crown Jewel on this
list what other choice could there have
ever possibly been Steven Spielberg's
horror Thriller Masterpiece practically
invented the modern Blockbuster and
unlike a lot of decades-old Classics it
still holds up today for one thing the
script is well paced and endlessly
quotable here's to swimming with
bow-legged women
the characters from Roy scheiders
overwhelmed but determine Chief Roadie
to Murray Hamilton's sleazeback mayor
are believable and memorable and Quinn's
speech about the very real shark attack
on the crew of the torpedoed USS
Indianapolis in World War II is one of
the most unforgettable scenes in movie
history the scares still stand the test
of time and the Practical effects of age
better than those in almost all of the
Bargain Bin creature features that tried
and failed to recapture the magic of
this classic the baited the
skinny-dipping girl in the beginning of
the movie deserves a place among the
most chilling scares in horror movie
history
and we don't even have to mention that
simple Unforgettable dread-inducing
theme courtesy of the incomparable John
Williams we know you're already humming
it to yourself check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
Looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]